okay thank you yeah the last speaker yes
either it's good you can run late or
everyone will run and then you should
stop right so so I've really enjoyed the
last two days I want to thank the
organizers I mean it seems a wonderful
conference I guess I'm up here to talk
about something a little different and
that's why was to be announced and its
really I hope you stay but it's it's
kind of a failure I feel like that I
think the monitor I tried to do two
things and we you know one sort of work
I'll talk about in a second and when it
hasn't worked but we learned some things
so I think workshop there may be a good
place to do that I hope you agree and
you know I'll proceed I mean it's going
to touch on counting and coloring and
things like that I I do I'm the reason I
put the collar thing up I don't know I
like to start with a joke I can't think
of a really good one today so i guess
i'll skip that maybe that's a joke I
don't know this is a good one I I think
that my one of my best ones was I I once
did the first slide up side down after
I've been just a year at Georgia Tech
and my Dean didn't know it was obviously
a joke and we had the projector and I
had the AV people come up we were trying
to turn the connector and I think he was
sort of sweating I hired this [ __ ] you
know and we finally got it to work
anyway okay so so why don't worry what
are we talking so it was supposed to
well I think the sum of the animation
may be off oh it doesn't matter so you
know for CT is just stands for four
color theorem I think it was mentioned
was it yesterday that we're computer
scientists mostly so we believe it and
those of us who are mathematicians we
know five colors for sure usually all
know how to proof
I think I sort of believe it especially
you know there are now two computer
proofs but what we really always want to
know is a proof that somehow it's not
just humanly checkable because I think
there's a lot of discussion what is a
good proof and I know in this area some
of the proofs are quite long some people
have 96 page proofs for example and
obviously checking is really really
critical so one of the things you know
is sort of kill any surprise here but in
any event you all know the standard
definition you know take a planar graph
and you try to for color the vertices or
the countries depending how you like to
look at it it's been grazed since the
1800s it was proved i guess in the 70s
via appellate hakan original computer
proof and and now you know there's so
much shorter one computers are much
faster i remember going to the talk that
hakan gave it yell at the time i was i
guess is just beginning my career there
and he got asked one interesting
question what kind of computer did you
use because then we didn't really have
laptops and he said it was blue that was
this which if you know and you're old
enough that men it was an IBM mainframe
anyway so a couple of us I want to talk
about four color mating a human proof
approached and here's some of our
thought and I'll just give a quick kind
of kind of summary of this idea it's not
it's not very deep but it does apply to
some other open problems and sub gave
the play the punch line already anyway
Tate noticed in 1880 and I guess we all
agree that was a while ago right
eighteen eighty Hyo notice that it's
exactly equivalent to taking every by
connected cubic graph and asking if it
has an edge three coloring so those are
the same and it's a very neat proof if
you haven't ever looked at actually one
direction is really easy and the other
one's a little harder is the way it
works
listening to connected so it has no edge
that when you remove it it disconnects
the graph all right you understand what
I'm I'm saying okay I'm sorry so yeah I
should have probably said too anyway
bridgeless is it is his terminology but
it had to be a perfect colouring I mean
a usual coloring of the kind you all
talked about but you know every edge
gets red green or blue and you don't get
any bad edges like this you know two
Reds colliding so when we looked at and
we said well look you know what what
might we do if we were convert or
elasaur you know you know in computer
scientists well how about finding a
three edge coloring that doesn't make a
lot of errors it's like a very natural
question I mean we know because the four
color theorem is true and this is
equivalents and there's actually a
linear I think I think you can go at
linear time from one to the other so you
actually can get a fast coloring and
that's an interesting point the actual
proof by appellant hakan and then later
by Seymour and company not only both of
those groups not only prove there is a
coloring they find it and the original
profibus think of as n cube time all the
constants are not tiny but they're not
astronomical and later it went to
quadratic time so they actually proved
too much right I mean we are working on
an open problem one piece of advice is
don't prove too much no one asked this
in the 1880s I guess no one thought
about alguns but you don't have to have
an algorithm to solve this problem and
if we had a human readable proof that
just proved the existence of a coloring
I think that'd be pretty spiffy I mean
you know you can imagine so anyway we
looked at this and we said well maybe
there would be applications where if you
just made it this is supposed to be a
little oh you just made a small number
of errors you know maybe n over log in
or in over Ackerman inverse or something
very close to linear you almost missed
it you know you almost got them all
right okay but it's little oh and
what we could show is Israel clip
remember these are classic so we could
prove that if you are able to color an
arbitrary a cubic you know say that it
sounds like your your magic word but you
at eight graph that will mean something
that's bridgeless cubic planner if you
could edge color right appropriately and
not make a lot of errors then you're
done you proved before collector so we
thought it was kind of a neat neat idea
we sent it at least two once to a
conference I was telling one person over
break early we got rejected probably
correctly because maybe it was a little
bit wrong conference but I love that one
of the rejection reasons one of the
referees was why did we how could we
assume that every cubic graph of this
type had an even number of vertices now
I hope that's a joke feet right does
everybody know that Cuba graphs ten like
all of them will have an even number
okay so move on so how do we do this so
here's our paper it's 2013 it's left off
the it's like a journal graph there this
is some of the other people that worked
on it they were all at the Times grad
students like I'm they left and I kept
kind of arguing we should send it
somewhere so we finally did so it's a
little bit of older result so so let me
just explain it was a really simple idea
but what I like about it first of all I
think maybe there's a way to do that you
know that would be really cool we
couldn't do it we tried a little bit but
you could imagine some technology that
you know we haven't thought about to
just you know some clever algorithm that
makes mistakes now you make this into an
sdp semi-definite program and you prove
some really cool theorem that it doesn't
make too many earths I don't know is
that leasing interesting I hope yes I'll
skip a whole bunch of slides okay
alright so the way we mean here's how
you would obviously attack it I'm sure
so you have some planar graph you assume
it's a counterexample it might be a very
big graph it might be small it doesn't
really matter but you can't it's it's at
eight graph you can edge color it
appropriately but it only has one error
right so we want to show that you can
make a lot more errors so you just think
you should immediately think
amplification and that's what that's why
we were interested I think so what we
decided to do is to try to build an
amplifier so take the same graph that
can't be colored and you try to use this
to build a bigger graph that was a tape
counter example now you might say oh I'm
already done but of course these are in
connected so I've got to send how bulan
edges and it's you know here's a high
level of the amplifier you have the
original graph with many errors of
course this goes on for a long time you
add an edge and you add little gadgets
that I'm not going to explain the super
details but what you have to show is the
following let's suppose you had an
algorithm that only made three hours
right then what would happen is one of
these structures would actually be three
I'm sorry yeah 3 color edge color
correctly the trouble is you've got it
you've got to color this not with this
junk hanging off it there's the junk
thats hanging off is sort of extra stuff
it might actually make that graph easier
to color so the argument which is not
hard and certainly does not take a lot
of pages what was the comment one of the
earlier talks everything that's easy is
almost trivial is that was near near
trivial that seemed almost like a
tautology and I won't say this is
trivial but it's not hard one of the
things that's neat about it is it really
has to use planarity in a serious way so
what you have to do is you take this
graph you've damaged you use some
duality tricks and remove things and
then you do you Zhu ality again
and eventually get that the original
graph is colorful so you know it's just
an amplifier tree and we've seen this
about all over computer science so
here's a graph coloring example that
that we did what what I liked about it
let me move on to my next you can also
do funky other things so you know you
could say well I could arrange these so
they diameter of this graph instead of
being linear stays small so you could
start to make conjectures which we've
thought about could you prove something
like if I have a planar graph may be
exponential in the diameter or not to
exponential in the diameter I could I
could color the edges to not make too
many hours you know maybe make number of
errors as a function of the diameter you
could you could arrange these graphs in
other ways in grids and other things now
I don't know I you know if we could
solve it we would that's what I would be
talking about I guess yeah so you know
i'm just i'm going to switch to
something else in a second I'm just
repeating it and by connected as same as
take graph here oh I don't know if
there's a real chance you know there's
our miracle we can prove that you take
one of these Tate graphs that you can
color it appropriately and not make a
lot of errors we just don't know how to
do that I wish I know an idea for that
you know if somebody gets a good one
well the the one thing that's nice about
this well I'll tell you sort of truth in
London you're lending I went to and we
have very strong graph theorists so
Robin Thomas they will be first figured
this out one to tell him I mean how do
you say I'm completely uninterested in
your result in a polite wake is a very
polite person I mean one he was you know
co-author of one of the the second
proves so he knows it's true even though
it's a computer true second this is not
the way he thinks right I mean if you
know the see more minor you know that
part of the world which I know
intersects very much with a lot of what
people do here they like very precise
terms that are about structure of graphs
and it's it's more I don't know it so
it's just a different kind of thing but
I did get him perk up a little bit
because we realized i think it's not in
the parent paper but we realized that
the same technology does work for some
open problems in graph flow problems so
you could talk to me offline but there
are a whole bunch of questions about
taking graphs in building know where
zero flows and other kinds of flows on
graphs just existence questions that
kind of generalized the four color
theorem in certain ways and they're open
but the same tricks actually work so you
can build an amplifier so again for
those slow problems you could say Oh
could I show I could at least not
violate the constraints too often all
right so I'd like to switch to a
different part I guess if there's any
questions you can interrupt any time and
is this okay all right I'll even use a
different background so you know it's
something so how to prove yeah I'm
supposed to say how not to but yes sure
okay I mean I guess I might but I don't
believe this but I really think p finna
glumpy but not sharpie but obviously a
field sharpie there's some issues here
at this meeting especially right anyway
so I'd like to like to say thank you
your so this is a pretty sure at 75 I
just really gotten to yell and he gave
the following talk i think was
essentially the key thing he said and
these are supposed to be subsets i just
couldn't find a symbol in the the time i
had any way he pointed out look you've
got large spaces you know contained in p
and NP and shark pnp space and he said
look we know you know this is classic
everyone knows by a diagonal is a shin I
mean these are way off right log verse
poly is not even close so that means of
course oh that's work here of course one
of these containments is strict
probably they're all many people would
believe that but right at least one is
strict which one no I guess that would
be really nice to know you know like
again with this group it would be very
bad if things collapse down to here for
you I don't have any secret punch line
coming up I get your word you know but I
you know anyway so so a long time ago I
said well let's try you know no my spare
time let's think about but the obvious
one I thought oh what too sensitive the
obvious one I thought was to look at the
biggest gap so the biggest gap at least
for me we could add their new classes of
course known but the biggest gap that
that seemed plausible that you might
feel to make some progress on was large
space against you know counting and
that's just you can't go too much
further gives you the hippie space it's
a theorem and you don't want to go to
below log space I mean you you know
maybe it's not so interesting so we you
know I mean this isn't stuff I've worked
on and we didn't get anywhere or I
didn't get any way brother but I
discovered some interesting things I
think okay so let me let me I won't
claim this as hard to say as d
rectangular ization problem i will not
say that 149 more times okay the show I
was listening okay so let me look this
something i'll just call the two line
prop so the deal is you've got a
directed graph it's it these are the
only edges these are supposed to be
directed edges and you have starts and
finishes starts and finishes notice this
is a different order so all you have is
to two long lines but you should think
of these lines that it really good
really long okay I mean gigantic and
your job is to figure out there's s 1 go
to terminal 1 or terminal 2 fair enough
I mean seems like an interesting
question what it has to do with
separating log space you'll see
so just to be a little more concrete
although we can play lots of games here
but imagine further that the graph that
you have either this graph for this
graph you have a small description of it
a small circuit and this even could be a
very special kind of circuit a really
simple kind of circuit but I'll get to
that in a little bit so that means what
do I mean I mean if you pick any vertex
it will tell you whether it's on one of
the lines its predecessor and successor
I'll tell you the starts and finishes
they're all ended you know in bit
strings so I've described it to you and
your job is to figure out this meant you
know who goes where and I would call it
the brute force algun we be just start
here and keep taking successors until
you hit something all right names good
so the question is can you do better in
a brute force and the answer is yes and
unfortunately i'll tell you how to do
this at least had some high level it's
not that complicated can well compared
to what you give it's simple but it has
a few ideas that I like so I'd like to
share them with you I think you might
enjoy and you may not know them but if
as you can do this and what I mean by
salt I'll be a little more precise in a
second but I think I'd rather explain
the Hat the how and you'll see why it's
sufficient all right is that already
affair with me so what you do is you
take the line and you connect them all
possible ways so what I mean is you you
can certainly put an artificial edge
here and an artificial edge here and
that would get one cycle or you can put
the edge from here to here in the edge
from here to here you know notice you
don't know which way you're doing it
right so you might agree that I'll take
the string labeled t1 and map it to
teach s1 and a strain t2s to so what am
I going to get well I'm going to get two
cycles or one so in the case we are I
guess correctly I'm going to get s 1 and
T 1 correctly I mean
get one huge directed cycle and I'm
going to get another one now actually in
our case you can even assume they have
the same size you know that's I don't
think that matters but it's an
interesting point and in this case oops
in this case it's of course twice the
size so you need to tell this apart I
mean that doesn't look like a lot of
progress I don't think unless you've
thought about a little bit because you
know your sort of stole in the brute
force position right where if you start
somewhere and start walking you know I
mean it's a long way around for both of
these okay so how do we do that well we
really can't take a chance i don't like
jumping back but i will these are really
permutations right every member every
vertex is a distinct string so you can
think of it as I'm mapping to this 1i
mapping this one so this is a
permutation on two cycles remember every
permutation has unique you know break up
into cycles so you've got it either a
permutation with two cycles or 10 so now
if i have a permutation is there some
cheap way to tell the number of cycles i
have without walking around and the
answer is sort of or at least not not
too difficult so here's here's the key
that i'm going to show you a little more
detail but it's basically the parity
meaning the number of permutation cycles
rather the number of cycles your
permutation has mod 2 is determined by a
relatively simple formula that you can
check fast or rapidly and of course we
know two and three are different i'm
going to point that out in a second
right i mean but here it's even worse to
is different than for now it's just just
some bad things but let's just
concentrate on to so if we could compute
the parity of the number of cycles then
obviously we're done right because it's
even even or odd ok
no jutsu every permutation is is a
collection of cycles right right so oh
you know you're talking about
transpositions that's something else
that's right that's right now no I don't
want to do that yeah actually not not
right so just you know if we just have
everybody point to somebody in this
group and everyone over there we'd have
two cycles all right we're just take our
names and use it for you understand so
we're on like okay so we have a draft of
some thing I guess I felt there was
going to leave this out but I felt I
need some mathematical formula otherwise
maybe I don't belong here and and
something I would some some envy of all
these talks with lots and lots of
symbols anyway okay I guess joke okay so
this is from a draft of a paper I could
share with someone there inches which is
actually relatively long not because
it's hard as this has a lot of details
about things anyway suppose that prize a
permutation you know over the usual
thing within objects and supposed to
those m cycles then there's this formula
which I've never actually found the name
for I mean I know how she knew it i'm
sure i don't know maybe you know maybe
euclid did but at least if someone in
the room you know can tell me later or
real time you're looking it up in google
i don't know exactly where i saw this
but in any event it's a theorem so let's
just see what it says it says that the
number of cycles e is equal to mod to
the number of inversions which you have
to compute and the number of points now
the number of points it turns out i'll
even tell you it's not going to help you
or you can put that in your key i'm
going to have to do some county so
counting a number of points is the
easiest part counting the number of
inversions is the harder part all right
so and if you want to know why this is a
formula if you doubt me
you know I don't know if I really it's
really quite simple but here's Lisa
proof the way I think about it I just
real able the cycles since it's not hard
to show that the way you label things
doesn't change anything and if you label
them one two three and then repeat you
get the total number of inversions is
this simple formula and since it's that
you get pie in version of pie and the
number of these is m and the number of
things you're taking off is in and of
course the minus goes away cuz it's 1 to
the power of working 12 anyway so it's
not a hard theorem to prove so so how do
we actually I didn't I didn't save it so
so I'm going to come back to that but
for the moment what you can think is
suppose we're back with this extremely
long line suppose we had some Counting
you know maybe we have sharp P but only
applying it to a very little
representation so you can start to see
we get some complexity theory
consequences right I mean possibly the
trouble is this problem on two lines
which I think if you haven't figured out
prior to this we hadn't seen a proof of
this maybe there are other proofs you
might be a little surprised that you
could do this by just counting simple
things like inversions I mean at least I
thought that's sort of what hooked me in
and I spent more hours than I care to
admit thinking about this because it
just seemed kind of to me a little
magical that you could do this for two
cycles just as you can help to from what
or that you give up to parody want to
now here's the here's the problem the
problem is is something I'll call the
three line problem which you know you
can already guess I don't have to write
it all out but the three line problem
now has three starts and three terminals
and you have to find you know who you
really connect to and of course there
are 16 different ways you know hole mole
factorial can occur so you could try the
same thing and obviously you know one
one possibility is you get maybe you
cross connect these and get this that
would be to side
or you get you guessed correctly that
would be three cycles well you can tell
too from 30 because everything we said
would work the amount of how many cycles
you had so if you could somehow reduce
it to telling to from three you would
actually be good and the reason it's
really good is this turns out to be good
enough to encode blog space I'm sorry
encode counting you know in count encode
a complexity class high enough up that
would be interested so so this is you
can do that and three is somehow you
know again sometimes things are special
it's just too doesn't work and sometimes
I prove that right because if you could
really show how to map fairly general
computations into telling a two-cycle
problem since I've solved that we'd
already be done and we could celebrate
after this which I guess we're going to
do anyway because it's in the days over
not because anything you know I'm saying
but you see so 3 is really important so
how do you go all right this is kind of
where I got stuck and I did a whole
bunch of things let me tell you a couple
of things and I'm not going to go too
much longer so I'm just saying we can so
we can solve the two line problem you
can even that you don't even need
sharpie on small objects you can even do
it all in polynomial time provided the
circuit that decides successor and
predecessor is easy and I want to
explain what that is in a sec that's not
a good definition and I think it's
actually equivalent to something that we
know but I didn't want to use that for
some reasons but three lines don't yield
to parody 1 verse 3 what's going to
happen is you're going to guess and
you're going to get one verse 3 and you
just stuck all right I mean it's just
the way at least I'm stuck okay so
here's here's a very simple way to
define think of this as the successor or
the predecessor of relationship that
that encodes the graph on strings of say
make they're all exactly left in and
what we're going to do is we're going to
say there's a finite automata
that if it's given the two strings
stacked above each other you you can
build a finite of time and other checks
that x.x is followed by why that's a
very simple kind of circuit right
everybody understand I'm is your
standard name for stacking things as I'm
it's a good trick that we've use all the
time you do you you've seen this before
no doubt most of us I can't resist
inside i think i have a few minutes this
trick of stacking this way you can need
to following if you teach fun at a time
in a theory earth if you don't know the
following theorem it's a cute one it's
actually like sisters book and and I'm
absolutely sure you know what do they
say I've taught that person everything
they know when Mike I can say I talked
him I told him one thing I know because
he once took finite automata theory for
me and I taught him this truck so anyway
the trick is that you can prove things
like pressburger arithmetic which is the
first order theory if you don't recall
first order theory of addition it it's a
classic theorem that it's decidable and
it's not actually terribly badly
decidable but using finite automata
theory you can using the stacking trick
you can prove the side ability
unfortunately get a terrible bound but
it's still decidable and the reason that
works there is that you can think of
this the automata is going to check
actually save 3 and X to the line is e
and check that X plus y equals Z and
notice the etomidate just has to keep
carries so it actually has a very small
state there by following the idea and
i'm using the same thing so i'm saying
that you can even assume even though
those three lines are coding a Turing
machine computation which could be
pretty complicated it's a very local
computation so you can code it this way
all right so
here's what we can prove if if this 3
line problem was doable in this case
where the the actual graph is described
in this very simple way then then we
would get you know we would solve your
asses question of course it not really
do to yours but we would show that his
his slide can now be erased if he still
has it and we could get a nice not equal
we're not contained I don't know how to
do that so let me end I guess I haven't
ever at least five minutes or something
like that is that I've about right can i
just wear a sari Oh plenty of time to
fast okay all right tell you more
stories anyway I will tell you how I try
to attack this and I spent a lot of time
line and I think it's interesting I just
have really two slides so not let me
even before I even put up so if if we
can keep if we can count mod too often
we can count mod for right there are
lots of theorems like that right I mean
they're not not always the case it
depends on the objects but very often we
can do that County mod a different prime
is another business so we could count
mine three would be home free and it's
just more generally mathematically if
you think about it what we're really
doing is using the fact that the simple
I'm sorry the symmetric group has one
non-trivial isomorphic I'm sorry
homomorphism the you know the parody of
the permutation right I mean remember SN
is not simple the alternating group is
and so you go down one so basically
we're using that fact we're using the
fact that we can compute some character
over the symmetric group really easily
so if you could figure out ways to
compute some other character you could
also solve this problem so another way
to look at this if you believe that log
space less than a sharpie is not going
to be solved that that's that's false
but not that I'm going to solve it
you're going to solve it one thing
you're obligated to do is show you can't
find another character that's that's
computable in the same kind of local way
does that make sense to you all you see
how if you could do it just say month
free if you could pues mod 3 you would
be home free right I mean maybe nuts
yeah if you wanted to know just play the
cases so trust me on that but if you
could be a mod for you could do it also
so here's an old trick probably all know
this when I was just since I have time
I'll go over suppose you have a class of
sets you can compute their cardinality
mod 2 so suppose you want to count the
cardinality of that set in 14 so they're
mine another trick so the standard trick
at least I always knew was you create a
new set which consists of unordered
pairs of distinct elements from the set
all right and of course it's m2's to or
if you like 10 times n minus 1 over 2 so
you've gone from em to a much bigger but
that's okay and what you basically do is
now count this mod 2 and you know so if
you know em of what I'm really saying if
you know an mod 2 and you know em choose
to mod to you can figure out m14 just
simple exercise and that's how you can
sort of ample that's another amplifier I
guess today's all amplifiers for me but
that's like an amplifier right you're
taking the number building all the
pair's getting more information just out
of the mud to Oracle you've got so you
know the first thing I thought about was
well don't just do this in an obvious
way for cycles or for permutations and
then trouble I ran into it is i found an
idea but it doesn't it doesn't work
exactly but it seems interesting it has
a lot of unusual properties and given
the time even with the extra time not
going to tell you but i tried to do
something like this so what I needed was
a way to take a graph that represented
but you know cycles and somehow build
its unordered pairs structure so I mean
no here's here's an obvious idea you
take the graph and say Asuma grab just
consists of directed cycles what the
vertices just be the unordered pairs
and say there's an edge from x y if x is
successors x prime and y is successor is
y prime right does that seem you know
sort of plausible I mean it and I've
looked around i'm not saying this is i
mean i think it even says new graph
power you can do you can be generalized
this to a crab product you know because
there's no reason to graph has to be the
same i have some evidence because some
people like to think i push this on the
block a couple years ago now and got
some people sending me papers working on
this new product or something so i have
i think there's a book forgot the exact
title but it's like gref powers or graph
products that's you know 400 pages of
every possible direct product Lex
product what are some of the other ones
actually had only different products of
graphs they're almost all replaced this
by ordered pairs and the trouble would
ordered pairs is is well that's why we
picked unordered pairs you needed the M
choose to if you want to M Squared you'd
be you just were just doesn't work so
you really need the unordered structure
so when I speed strange properties sort
of have you prepare this life but when
you take a graph and say even just
square it or raise it or cubed what
happens is it's not obvious what the
cycle structure is I mean I've you know
I worked on in and have a whole bunch of
lemons of how that works for small
powers but I don't know it's just to end
what i mean is i guess i can put this
down so what I'm saying is if you take
this graph I don't you know we need a
new symbol but you know I don't know say
that this one is squaring I was trying
to say you could even imagine a you know
taking two graphs but what happens if
you take a directed cycle the nasty
thing that happens is when you when you
do this what you'd really like is if you
start out with a graph with
with you know the M or say k cycles
you'd like to go to K choose to then you
be done or something like that doesn't
have exactly K choose to but some
reasonable function that let you get
squeezed information but what happens is
you get shortcuts you get graphs when
you take a cycle sometimes when you just
say square you may find that you don't
just get several fours you get some twos
because there are short ways to go and
somehow that doesn't happen when you
just take objects and make them
unordered pairs you did that with the
vertices but now the edges you know so
what would happen almost done what what
happened is if you had a path that was
going like this say some left you you
might have it that if you skip every
other one you're going to get it you're
going to get a graph so what's going to
happen is the structure of the power
just say raise the two is not it's not
very simple am i clear yeah i'm just
about done so what I don't mean that
this won't work and I did spend some
time trying to prove and understand some
of the least low degree powers of graphs
under this operation this operation may
have other applications and that would
be cool and like I said I have you know
studied it with trying to prove some
things but they're a whole bunch of
conjectures in the real sense of
conjectures that I couldn't prove that I
didn't really understand how this this
product really worked in general I mean
of course I do but you know in the same
way we would hear sometimes about
dichotomy and you really would like to
have a closed form or something very
simple describing what is G to the you
know 2 to the K or something what does
that really look like in terms of cyclo
structure and it's not it's not at least
to me it doesn't seem very simple so I'd
like to stop there and thank you again
and
so in any of you saw I've questions so
any any of you going to work on four
color theorem at least think about this
okay not not going to happen all right
oh no now I challenge you this is a
separation trouble yeah well I do yeah I
mean if I you know I i fell in fairmount
timeline I think Italy's avoids the
known obstacles like many unnatural
proofs and Oracle's because it's looking
it's ripping things apart and you know
it's using theorems that don't
relativize so and don't seem to hit the
other stuff I I thought I was you know I
mean we get a lot of why I don't like
don't use the word I use the word
amateur or long some but we can't know
because the visibility we have does
block we get a lot of people claiming
you know people's entry fee not equal
and B I was like well once you shoot for
something simpler like we don't even
know if sat can't be done in linear time
you know give me a proof that you could
prove you know it takes at least super
linear time to do SAT i would be very
excited so I think there's some hope
here I did put a lot of time I do like
this if it seems like i can i can really
reduce this you know if you wanted to
talk a blunt to some very simple
questions about this operator or maybe
some other operators anyway so that my
answer is yeah i'll probably still think
about it but kind of off it for a while
right now i think we had 0 food food is
too important ok food I mean I can't
stop you from eating thanks again for
inviting me